i'm here about to surprise my old
neighbors i've been away in europe for
two years i don't do the internet i
think it's toxic so i lose touch with
people
so easily and i'm so excited they love
this cake they're gonna flip
jeff just lame they're like the best
people i mean they ran some charity for
women or something deeply inspiring so
many rich people don't do a lot for the
community these two did
they're probably in the pool sometimes
they're underwater he swam laps i mean
they were both in great shape
i went to their island once and there
was so much blood on the floor
from the calves that they had
slaughtered to feed the local
townspeople
let's eat this cake maybe they're on a
new diet
i'm starting to think maybe something's
wrong i
am so shocked
i just logged onto the internet for like
the first time in two years
donald trump is racist